guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their farms
earthquakes
you should be killed
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount
code salam 10 for 10 of their products
because apparently apparently i said we
should go and bounce here
okay
[Applause]
jesus
[Applause]
[Applause]
earthquakes
listen listen
[Applause]
oh
look at this you should be killed this
is actually
this is this is this is a question
he's saying that i should be
don't finish
is
[Applause]
this is why you see the moment we bring
the bible
yeah they have to bounce because you
know why you want to come to me about
apostasy
your book this is guys they believe
jesus is god yeah
who's the god of the old testament
jesus is the god of the old testament
but jesus says
if anyone worships another god kill him
and you want to continue apostasy i'll
make you very clear
in islam we have apostasy laws that's in
place in a legitimate islamic government
not a single place that i said that you
need to go to bounty hunt for ex-muslims
that's a lie that's absolute lie so with
the moment we opened the book of
jeremiah
the moment we got to the book of
deuteronomy where jesus
the god of the old testament says if
anybody leaves their religion
they talk about apostasy but they don't
know the whole bible if you go to your
own bible
man the bible is rough go to the book of
samuel
it says get get kill men women children
babies
and the donkey what the hell did the
donkey do the donkey's chilling now
i'm about to visit my own business kill
the donkey what do you want from the
donkey
guys i challenge any christian to find
me a verse
like this that says kill men women
children babies it says get babies and
smash them on the rocks
smash smash and you want to come to your
violence
show me a single place in the quran we
are forbidden
to harm trees that's the reason why guys
when we come with the truth they have to
run away like a coward
like a little boy a little boy they had
to run away guys yeah
and handle it we are here to expose
these guys and you know why
let me tell you something in this park i
can tell you minimum
maybe 100 people came to islam have you
ever seen one video someone come to
christianity
one one aggie one half half
and this is the why this is the reason
why they die in their rage
yeah and allah says buy your hands out
of rage alhamdulillah
on tape it's on tape and that's the
reason why
guys these guys are cowards okay
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
you